what would you do if you thought your
country was on the path to tyranny if
you saw one man gaining too much power
would you try to stop them even if that
man was one of your closest friends and
allies these were the questions haunting
Roman senator Marcus Junius Brutus in 44
BCE the Year Julius Caesar would be
assassinated opposing unchecked power
wasn't just a political matter for
Brutus it was a personal one he claimed
descent from Lucius Junius Brutus who
had helped overthrow the tyrannical king
known as Tarquin the proud
instead of seizing power himself the
elder Brutus led the people in a rousing
oath to never again allow a king to rule
Rome became a republic based on the
principle that no one man should hold
too much power now four and a half
centuries later this principle was
threatened julius caesar's rise to the
powerful position of consul had been
dramatic years of military triumphs had
made him the wealthiest man in Rome and
after defeating his rival Pompey the
great in a bitter Civil War his power
was at its peak his victories and
initiatives such as distributing lands
to the poor had made him popular with
the public and many senators vied for
his favor by showering him with honors
statues were built temples were
dedicated and a whole month was renamed
still called July today more importantly
the title of dictator meant to grant
temporary emergency powers in wartime
had been bestowed upon Caesar several
times in succession and in 44 BCE he was
made dictatorial dictator for a
potentially unlimited term all of this
was too much for the Senators who feared
a return to the monarchy their ancestors
had fought to abolish as well as those
whose own power and ambition were
impeded by Caesars rule a
group of conspirators calling themselves
the liberators began to secretly discuss
plans for assassination leading them
were the senator Gaius Cassius Longinus
and his friend and brother-in-law Brutus
joining the conspiracy was not an easy
choice for Brutus
even though Brutus had sided with Pompey
in the ill-fated Civil War Caesar had
personally intervened to save his life
not only pardoning him but even
accepting him as a close advisor and
elevating him to important posts Brutus
was hesitant to conspire against the man
who had treated him like a son
but in the end Cassius insistence and
Brutus's own fear of Caesars ambitions
won out the moment they had been waiting
for came on March 15th at a Senate
meeting held shortly before Caesar was
to depart on his next military campaign
as many as 60 conspirators surrounded
him unsheathing daggers from their togas
and stabbing at him from all sides as
the story goes caesar struggled fiercely
until he saw Brutus
despite the famous line at tu brute a
written by Shakespeare
we don't know Caesars actual dying words
some ancient sources claim he said
nothing while others record the phrase
and you child fueling speculation that
Brutus may have actually been caesar's
illegitimate son but all agree that when
Caesar saw Brutus among his attackers he
covered his face and gave up the fight
falling to the ground after being
stabbed 23 times unfortunately for
Brutus he and the other conspirators had
underestimated Caesars popularity among
the Roman public many of whom saw him as
an effective leader and the Senate as a
corrupt aristocracy within moments of
Caesars assassination
Rome was in a state of panic most of the
other senators had fled while the
assassins barricaded themselves on the
Capitoline Hill Mark Antony Caesars
friend and co-consul was Swift
to seize the upper hand delivering a
passionate speech at Caesars funeral
days later that whipped the crowd into a
frenzy
of grief and anger as a result the
liberators were forced out of Rome the
ensuing power vacuum led to a series of
civil wars during which Brutus facing
certain defeat took his own life
ironically the ultimate result would be
the opposite of what the conspirators
had hoped to accomplish the end of the
Republic and the concentration of power
under the office of emperor opinions
over the assassination of Caesar were
divided from the start and have remained
so as for Brutus himself few historical
figures have inspired such a conflicting
legacy in Dante's Inferno he was placed
in the very center of Hell and eternally
chewed by Satan himself for his crime of
betrayal but Swift's Gulliver's Travels
described him as one of the most
virtuous and benevolent people to have
lived the interpretation of Brutus as
either a selfless fighter against
dictatorship or an opportunistic traitor
has shifted with the tides of history
and politics but even today over 2,000
years later questions about the price of
Liberty the conflict between personal
loyalties and universal ideals and
unintended consequences remain more
relevant than ever
you